hello and welcome to this video playing
brawny Mia its brawny Mia magazine which
if i'm not mistaken yep yeah i read that
recently against Yardbird and won the
game so i'll repeat it even though had
some doubts about my opaque position i
had a decent position later in the game
but still oh wow yeah that idea wasn't
it was part of behind mehreen spoke
right and this disguise a good
theoretician he has co-authored some
recent books of the french defence and
also about the big win ian and the
modern bogo it's a book that I'm checked
when i wrote a road mine of course
yeah 97 and then ultimately g5 was was
coming and here at least them he's got
some clear idea play on the UM play on
the sea fowl hmm
and one day I should play c6 en takes
Knight takes 92 @ diagonal I think I'll
play I play this but i'm not sure what
this 92 c forum is obviously coming
yeah it wasn't the greatest idea ever it
really wasn't especially now when I'm
going back again maybe I can play b5
here as funny as it looks but that's it
is better than it looks let's say which
still doesn't make it great but this is
this so badly it's just so bad here that
looks kind of okay with f5 coming hmm i
don't know i really expect them to take
away the rook to at least have some
ideas with Roxy 7 or things like that I
should play a five-year to be ready to
take my anyway not a big deal that fr
therefore idea is pretty good anyway
ablex Bishop here is a lot stronger than
whites yeah d5 now as a tactic should I
go for that it's probably the right way
to play to break through him takes
Bishop takes wins material even though
it's don't really want to give up the
bishop it will be honest check but I
guess I have to
so what to put to pull out to play the
same d3 is weak I guess route before
then 26 maybe where Gabe's got Bishop
before coming
right sorry it's not that easy I forgot
if you get Bishop before
okay I need to activate my pieces here
so let's see if I can detect be 225 rook
e8 h okay okay I grabbed this happy to
grab more points here that erupted you
three as well Queen f2 may be here that
looks good 25 route III
oops ah come on I didn't see that one
coming
I am an idiot I'm such an idiot from
that position and now I still struggle
here are my goodness hmm how to do that
shoot that's especially unnecessarily
when former completely from a completely
um yeah from a position where I was
completely in control honest what I'm
trying to say now he has has real
drawing chances
maybe I can still win here the torque so
I just stronger in this type of position
but he might get enough common to play
there was g5 and stuff open up open up
my king
check
check check check
check hmm it's probably just a draw
check check check check check what a
joke just ran into rook everyone yeah
just can do whatever and win just not
this what I did yeah also a five you can
run the pawn minus six is the engines
evaluation here yeah it's pretty awful
to not win the game ok so this position
here is just better for black and then
don't really know why you went for us it
wasn't necessary at all could have done
many many other things adhere f5f was
just coming and black is far easier to
play him and the way it went it was a
was a win because he run into this into
this check take check you hear the only
thing that I should have done is just
win the game yeah can check I mean this
is this is still better for black but
it's it's difficult to do especially
with one minute the he got in g5 and and
so on maybe I had some chances to to
prevent that but I doubted rook cc7 g6
the other I had the suspicion that this
might be right to be honest but with no
time it was clear that here I'm never
losing a week it's also easy to play and
this was what I was thinking as a
possible way to
try to try to win but it's probably
still a draw because he has all those
chicks yeah that was pretty terrible not
winning this game okay thanks for
watching